we are now only a couple of days away
from apple's wwdc event on june 6 which
is monday and i am extremely excited
because we've been getting more and more
leaks and rumors coming in over the past
week that are confirming the different
products and features that we should be
seeing and the ones that we definitely
should not now before we get into the
actual hardware releases that we should
expect because yes we are expecting some
hardware i want to try and crack some of
the easter eggs like first of all apple
just released this new graphic with the
new wwdc logo and there are some
interesting points to mention here this
twitter user pointed out that the new
imac has seven colors and this new
graphic actually has seven different
colors including the silver macbook pro
so what if this points to an upcoming
macbook air with seven different colors
just like the imac because that's what
some of the leaks were pointing to over
the last couple of months and on top of
that we did finally get apple's official
hash flag on twitter which is wwdc22
and it shows their little swift logo but
with an rgb wheel going around it and
going even crazier apple actually teased
wwdc 2022 with these new augmented
reality memoji cards which show a bunch
of different colors and basically it's
almost like collectible cards kind of
like a pokemon card pack that you can
open up and in my opinion all of those
different rgb colors including the
collectible card packs that you open up
remind me of gaming so my thought is
what if apple has some major gaming
announcements to make and the crazy
thing is we actually have some leaks and
rumors that give some evidence to my
thoughts first of all we had the leaks
of apple talking to ea games electronic
arts to try and buy them out now on top
of that apple has also been making new
patent filings for new gaming
controllers for the iphone kind of like
the new backbone one controller that i
recently reviewed and i think it's the
absolute best choice for apple if
they're going into gaming now moving on
we also got some very interesting leaks
and rumors from mark german who was the
most reliable apple analyst and leaker
and he gave us a lot of different
software features that we should be
seeing first of all for ios 16 he says
that apple is planning major
enhancements for the lock screen
including wallpapers that have
widget-like capabilities which is very
very interesting and then he said that
we could be getting an always-on lock
screen
finally on the iphone 14 pro later this
year when it actually comes out now in
terms of ipad os 16 he says that he's
expecting major changes to windowing and
multitasking which we've actually made a
video on right here showing off some
different apple patents and different
leaks that show that apple is going to
completely revamp the multitasking on
the ipad pro and ipad air making it a
lot more pro and then on top of that he
expects the messages app to gain more
social network like functionality
particularly around audio messages now
he doesn't think the health app is going
to make it to ipad os or mac os although
plenty of new features are said to be on
the way that work with the iphone and
the apple watch and in terms of watch os
9 it's allegedly going to include
significant improvements to watch os
that affect day-to-day operating and
navigation so maybe it's going to be
easier to navigate and potentially a new
low power mode which is definitely going
to be awesome because the current one is
just like a power reserve that doesn't
work very well on top of that the iphone
and the apple watch is going to be
getting a new car crash detection
feature which works to automatically
dial 911 if you get into a car crash and
you don't respond so that is gonna be
saving a lot of lives now let's move on
we have some leaks from mcguire wood or
geo riku he says he has some new leaks
that are scheduled to come out
throughout the week but he did give us a
little bit of sneak peeks right here
first of all he's got some ipad stuff
he's got the macbook air that he thinks
is coming he's got the m2 series which
is awesome and even the mac pro with
apple silicon and some apple tv stuff as
well and right here he even said there's
opportunity for a mac pro with an m
series processor and a new heat sink
design and he's currently trying to get
some pictures of it from his source so
that's a little sneak peek but we'll
talk about that in just a minute first
let's move on to apple's vr headset and
we got a major leak from robert scobol
he says that apple's wwdc event is going
to be the first of three different
events apple is preparing for the next
year to introduce the world to augmented
reality a new form that we haven't seen
yet now the first event is going to be
wwdc where they're going to introduce a
new development environment for a new
kind of photo realistic 3d scene avatars
and much more and then the second event
is when apple is actually going to
reveal the ar vr headset probably in
january 2023 with bleeding edge
technology and then the third event
around june 2023 which is wwc next year
is when apple is finally going to sell
that headset and the crazy thing is that
ming chaquel completely agreed with them
saying that it's unlikely for apple to
reveal their mixed reality headset at
wwdc
and it's actually going to get launched
next year just like robert scoble was
saying so in my opinion based on
mingxiquo's tweets i think apple is
going to give us a sneak preview or
introduce us into the world of apple's
metaverse with their augmented reality
but they're not going to show us all of
the details that other companies can
copy and the crazy thing is that mark
german basically agrees saying that the
vr headset is unlikely and according to
mark he says that if there's any
hardware at wwdc it'll likely be on the
mac side and he says that it could be
the next macbook air with the m2 chip
because there are more and more signs
that employees are actually using the
next gen in macbook air with their apps
which is a sign that the new mac is
close and i know we've been making quite
a few videos on this new macbook air but
let me just refresh your memory with
some of the features that we should be
expecting on the new macbook air first
of all we should be getting a redesigned
chassis which i think is going to look
more like the 14 inch macbook pro in
terms of the new design which is going
to be flat on the top and bottom we're
also expecting white bezels and a white
keyboard and on top of that we are also
expecting a notch which is unfortunate
but it's what they did with the 14 inch
macbook pro and allowed the bezels to be
slimmer which is always good and of
course like i talked about earlier on in
the video we should be expecting
multiple colors as well a slightly
larger lcd display which ross young
confirmed saying that it's going to be
0.3 inches larger which basically
confirms the whole notch idea and i do
believe it's going to have an m2 chip we
should also expect a 1080p webcam we
should expect max save 3 just like on
the 14 inch macbook pro and two
thunderbolt ports as well and here's an
awesome tweet from mark german basically
showing that the macbook air is
currently the only regular m1 mac other
than one imac configuration that's
showing any signs of shipping delays
which means that we could be seeing the
macbook air coming next week now on top
of that mcguire wood actually went in
detail with some extra leaks and
finalized rumors he says that the
macbook air refresh is happening yes
it's happening with new colors and a
modified chassis design a slightly
larger battery with the m2 chip and no
face id in the top display camera area
this year which basically shows that yes
it's going to have a notch and he also
said that battery life is going to be
comparable to the current m1 macbook pro
thanks to improved efficiency of the new
m2 chip which is awesome because the m1
macbook pro actually has the best
battery life out of any mac right now
even better than the m1 macbook air so
the m2 macbook air is going to catch up
to it now moving on to some
disappointing news we have to talk about
the m2 chip because shrimp apple pro
gave us some bad news about the a16 and
the m2 saying that it's going to be
based on the old generation tsmc n5p
process which is second generation 5
nanometer and that's for both the a16
and the new chip which first of all he
thought it would be the m1x or something
based on the m1 but he came out later
and said that his source agrees that the
m1x could be the actual m2 instead
because it's all about marketing and it
makes sense for apple to call it the m2
and if you're struggling to imagine what
it's going to look like you can check
out my renders that i made with renders
by shailesh and i think that these new
macbook airs are going to be absolutely
stunning and now with that said we have
another very interesting leak first of
all an apple memo said that the original
ipad pro and strangely the apple tv hd
will become vintage products next month
now that was in may so this month in
june they're going to be vintage and the
crazy thing about this is that the apple
tv hd is actually still up for sale on
apple's website however this might mean
that they could be replacing it with
something totally new and guess what
major quote just came out with a leak
last month saying that apple is going to
be launching a new version of the apple
tv that improves cost structure in the
second half of 2022 which is basically
as early as july and in my opinion i
think that apple is actually making a
low-cost streaming stick just like the
amazon fire tv stick because they can
bring the price down far below a hundred
dollars to basically push their apple tv
plus service and finally with all of
that out of the way let's talk about the
mac pro which we might see at wwdc
and here is the major leak that we got
from shrimp apple pro he says that the
m1 extreme the jade 4c which is
basically four m1 max dies put together
does exist and the only time it makes
sense to release that mac pro chip
is this year and the best time is wwdc
so i'm really hoping that we get that
report because we were getting some
leaks and rumors from people like majin
buu saying that there's gonna be a new
2022 mac pro and it's gonna connect two
m1 ultra chips together and even more
detailed he says that it's coming this
september which is insane and i really
hope they come that soon so with that
said the new mac pro could just have the
same chip that's modified and rebranded
as the m2 extreme or of course something
completely different like the x1 and
there you guys go that's everything you
should be expecting at wwdc and if
you're not already subscribed click the
circle above to do so right now because
i'm gonna keep you posted on all the
leaks that are coming up until wwc and
of course we're gonna cover anything
that launches there as well so if you
enjoy the video definitely check out
another video over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]